so now we start on another topic in
graph theory namely the topic of simple
graphs so last week we were talking
about directed graphs where the arrows
have a beginning and an end as shown
here but simple graphs are simpler the
arrows of the edges don't have direction
they just correspond to a mutual
connection which is symmetric so there's
a picture of a simple graph and the
edges are shown without an arrowhead a
special thing about directed graphs is
that it's possible to have an arrow
going in each direction between two
vertices but when we have undirected
edges like this that doesn't happen so
there's only one edge between a pair of
vertices in a simple graph in addition a
directed graph might have a self loop
and an edge that starts and begins at
the starts and ends at the same vertex
and those are also disallowed in simple
graphs now you could allow those things
there's a thing called multi graphs
where there are multiple edges between
vertices and there could also be self
loops but we don't need those let's not
complicate matters we're talking about
simple graphs ok so the formal
definition of a simple graph is that
it's an object G that has a bunch of
parts namely it has a non-empty set V of
vertices just like directed graphs and
it has a set of e a set of edges but the
edges now are somewhat different since
they don't have beginnings and ends an
edge just has two end points that are
envy and we don't distinguish the end
points so let's just draw a picture
here's a case where there are six
vertices V shown in blue and there are
these undirected edges shown in green in
this case I see seven edges in E there's
an example of an edge that goes between
two vertices that I've highlighted in
yellow and red and we've made that
particular edge dark green an edge like
that can formally be represented as just
the set of its endpoints a set of two
things red and yellow in text will often
indicate it as the two vertices
connected by a horizontal bar but you
have to remember that the order in which
the red and the
occur don't matter because it's really a
set consisting of red and yellow when
two vertices are connected by an edge
they're said to be adjacent and the edge
is said to be incident to its endpoints
just a little vocabulary that we use
here now a basic concept in graph theory
which is what we're going to make a
little bit of in this video segment is
the idea of the degree of a vertex the
degree of a vertex is simply the number
of incident edges the number of edges
that touch it the number of edges for
which it's an end points so let's look
at the red vertex there are two edges
incident to the red vertex so its degree
is 2 okay let's look at the yellow
vertex on here there are four edges
incident to the yellow vertex so its
degree is for no surprises yet so let's
examine some properties of virtus vertex
degrees that are motivated by a simple
example suppose I ask the question is it
possible to have a graph with vertex
degrees of two two and one so implicitly
it's a three vertex graph and a one
vertex has degree 2 another has degree 2
and one has degree 1 well let's see what
it looks like um if I'm going to have a
vertex of degree 1 then I know what it
looks like there's the vertex it's got
one edge out of it it's going to some
other vertex now this other vertex must
have degree too so it's connected to
something else and the something else
must be another vertex with degree too
because those are the only possible
spectrum of degrees one two and two and
that means that this last guy has has to
have an edge out of it because it's
degree 2 and it can't go back to 2
because there aren't any there's already
an edge between these two and it can't
go back to one because that has degree 1
so we're stuck and by this ad hoc
reasoning we figured out that there
can't be a degree 3 graph with this
spectrum of degrees two to one it's
impossible well we could have reasoned
more general in there's a very
elementary property of degrees that
we're going to actually make something
of in a minute and it's called the
handshaking lemma it says that the sum
of the degrees of summed over all the
vertices is
equal to twice the number of edges there
it is written as a formula twice the
number of edges so that's the
cardinality symbol absolute value of a
set means the size of the set here is
fine I twice the number of edges is
equal to the sum over all the vertices
of the degree of the vertices why is
that true well if you think about it and
the sum on the right every edge is
counted twice once for each vertex that
it's the end of so we're really just
counting this is way of summing up over
all of the vertices in which each vertex
gets numerated twice so the sum is twice
the number of vertices and the proof is
kind of trivial but let's make something
of this you might wonder why it's called
the handshaking lemma that will emerge
in in some problems that we're going to
have you to do but let's go on and apply
the handshaking lemma in an interesting
way and by the way of course since two
plus two plus one is odd we could have
without that ad hoc analysis figured out
that the sum of the degrees can't be odd
because it's twice something all right
so here's the application that's
designed to get your attention it is an
application of graph theory to sex and
we ask the question are men more
promiscuous than women and there have
been repeated studies that are cited in
the notes that show again and again that
when they survey collections of men and
women ask them how many sexual partners
they have it's consistently the case
that the men are assessed to have thirty
percent more seventy four five percent
more sometimes two and a half times
three times as many partners as the
women and there's got to be something
wacky about this we're going to come up
with a very elementary graph theoretic
argument that says that this is complete
nonsense by the way the most recent
study that we could find was one that's
mentioned in the notes in 2007 by the US
Department of Health and the
statistician who collected the data know
that the results were impossible but her
job was to report the data not to
explain it or interpret it and the men
reported thirty percent more partners
than the women
we're going to show that somebody's
lying here's how we're going to do it
we're going to model the relationships
between men and women by having a graph
that comes in two parts it's going to be
called a so-called bipartite graph so
there's going to be one set of vertices
called em and another set of vertices
called F mmmm for men and F for women or
females and we are going to have edges
going between men and women between MS
and FS precisely when they have been
involved in a sexual liaison so looking
back at this graph this edge from that a
blue m to that orange F indicates that
they had had a sexual release on they
were partners okay so this is a simple
graph structure that we can use to
represent who got together with whom in
any given population of men and women
now if you think about the same argument
that we use for handshaking if you sum
the degrees of the men you're counting
each edge exactly once and so the sum of
the degrees of the men is equal to the
number of edges in this graph and
likewise if you sum over the females uh
you're counting each edge once and so
the sum of the female degrees is also
equal to the number of edges in
particular the sum over the degrees of
the males is equal to the sum over the
degrees of the females because every
time there's a liaison it involves one
male one female all right now let's do
this do a little bit of elementary
arithmetic i'm going to divide both
sides of this equality by the size of
the male population by the number of men
and if i do that i get this formula the
left-hand side is the number of is the
sum of the degrees of men / the size of
the m population and here i'm doing a
little trick notice that the f's cancel
out but I've expressed this some of the
female degrees divided by M as the sum
of the female degrees divided
by F times this factor f / M which is
the ratio of the populations of women to
men now the reason I'm doing this is
that if you look at this thing on the
left this is the average degree of the
men this is the sum of all the degrees
of men divided by the number of men so
it's the average number of partners that
men have and likewise now you can
recognize over here that I've got the
average number of partners that each
woman has and what we've just figured
out then is that there's a fixed
relationship between the average number
of partners of men the average degree of
the M vertices and the average degree of
the F vertices and these two average
degrees these average numbers of
partners is simply related by the ratio
of the populations the average men
degree is the female population divided
by the M population times the average
degree of the females now what that
tells us is that um these wild figures
of twice as many and thirty percent more
and so on are completely absurd because
we know a lot about the ratio of females
to males in the population as a matter
of fact in the US overall there are
slightly more women than men there's one
point 0 35 women for each man in the US
population and that tells us then that
when you if you surveyed the population
of all the men and women in the country
you would discover that the men looked
three and a half percent more had three
and a half percent more partners than
women per man but this has nothing to do
with their behavior or promiscuity or
lack of it it's simply a reflection of
the ratio of the populations which gets
us to the question of where do these
crazy numbers come from and the answer
seems to be that people are lying one
explanation would be that men exaggerate
their number of partners and women under
state their number of partners but the
truth is that nobody knows exactly
why we get these consistently false
numbers but we do get them consistently
in one survey after another you will no
longer be fooled by such nonsense